in this capsule we see the notion
of inference in the logic of the first
round
so we've already seen how you are
what is the syntax of logic
first round to describe facts that
are true mm teeth in a base of
knowledge now let's see the
second part that we need for
demonstrate the veracity of a new
expression know as attests that
can do by manipulations
syntactic do a derivation of
new expressions that are
logical consequences and specifically
worth to see the proof by resolution so
the rule of resolution that will work
which will allow us to do just that
it's this lot new derivation
expressions then validly so
general process of inference
processes that allow us to infer
formulas that are consequences
logical other formulas for example
they formulate in a database of
knowledge there are two properties that
will interest us in relation to
different processes the first one is
what the reference process is
correct ie is what the state
are all the formulas that go
be deduced by the different process
these are indeed consequences
logics of these formulas so in
other words to that one to the process
difference is only shores and
formulas that are valid that are
logical consequences or does this
would be the case where a different process
would not be correct or samedan English
is sometimes a process of inference
drifts expressions that are not
logical consequences so if we want
not if we want precise different what
is ok we would also like
different process what is
ideally complete to know that if I
specify an an expression and that this
expression is actually a
logical consequence of my base of
knowledge though my process
different this vote is capable of derivatives
this formula so in other words is
what my difference process is
able to infer any formula that is
a logical consequence of good in sum
initial basic formulas of anger
then one assures us that we are not going
derive that is wrong when we assures
we can all be derived
what is true here is an example two
examples in fact rules of inference
very simple the first step the words
from the spawn end who says that if I
formula f1 where the price of co is fine and
that I have the formula f1 explains f killer
so I can deduce f2 added to the
first logical expression list
rank in my knowledge base so
among other topics or a little this raid
is pure life so it would be
the equivalent of f1 here no forgiveness if
I had a little this live opus implies
all that would be the fire r2f equivalent
implies f2 and that i have additionally had a
this little help is a bit strife
would be f1 then according to the rule
of word inference available on Saturday that I
can add shu who can infer shoot
from these two formulas another
is different is the instantiation
universal that says that from for for
all xf1 I can deduce a formula f2
which would be obtained from f1 in
replacing all occurrences free
of my variable x so manage a variable
external
I replace all occurrences
free 2 x by internal a theme
whatever but who does not have any
variables in common with others
variables of f1 so that allows a little
more than we want a little complicated but a
very simple example of blood that allows
to understand what why this
difference in sense if i have like
for all etc so I have that all
dogs are the same do and then
if i have that fido is a dog ben i
can conclude that fido and finally to do
so marked that here I had a rule
which applied to all dogs so
I if I had fits logical form
after rob i will have a variable x here
his rule looks like something like
for any x dog x involves granny doing
so here I am writing you grandma x and fido
is a dog I could write as
dog
lemaitre who is it because I had it
put with a sim may not be the
water well so this rule says that at
from that and that I can infer
fido mammals
that's the instantiation rule
universal what we are going to
focus during the next caps
and on a more general rule that
call the resolution rule so that
will allow us among others first
like what particular rule modus
pony since universal instantiation
dawn it's going to be a procedure so
thanks to this rule we will be able to do
a proof by resolution that this
procedure must be correct and complete
under certain conditions we will see
in the next capsules and it was
a rule that will require several
tools that we will discuss in
different capsules these tools have it
correspond to what is called the
substitution unification
and then finally the transformation
in conjunctive normal form